[Music]
well that is a somber Brad Pitt arriving
Friday at the funeral of his good friend
Rob great Chris Cornell and that very
same day only about 30 miles away his ex
Angelina stepped out with four of their
kids for a very special occasion raising
her six kids as a single mom seems to be
weighing heavily on Angelina she tells
Elle France magazine she wishes her late
mother were there to help saying quote I
would give anything for her to be with
me at this time I've needed her I talked
to her often in my mind and try to think
what she might say and how she might
guide me Angie's mother marshalene
Bertrand died in 2007 of ovarian cancer
in 2011 Angelina spoke to the late Bob
Simon on 60 minutes about the impact of
her mother on her life my mother was it
was a full-time mother she didn't have
much of her her own career her own life
her own experiences her own you know
everything was for her children I will
never be as good a mother she was I
would try my best but I don't think I
could ever be she was she was just grace
incarnate she was the most generous
loving she's better than me Brad has
talked about going into therapy after
their split Jolie has primary custody of
their kids and calls them resilient she
says quote but they are children and as
much as they need help to understand the
hard truths in life they also need what
we all need protection and love
[Music]
you